Las políticas que desarrolla la Unión Europea
son fundamentales para los jóvenes
y también para el resto de la ciudadanía.
Pero obviamente
eh los jóvenes son el futuro de de la Unión Europea,
son eh nuestra promesa y por lo tanto
eh nos preocupa cuáles son sus preocupaciones también
y eh trabajamos
en en temas eh tan importantes para ellos
como puede ser el empleo,
la lucha contra el cambio climático,
esta legislación,
esta legislatura,
perdón, ha sido
eh la legislatura del pacto Verde y la lucha contra
eh el cambio climático.
También problemas de eh, salud física y mental
y temas de eh,
vivienda y cohesión social.
Y por supuesto,
el papel de los jóvenes
para la Unión Europea es imprescindible eh
tienen que demostrarnos el compromiso
por 1 Unión Europea más fuerte,
más solidaria
y y espero que eh en las elecciones
demuestren ese compromiso yendo a votar